nous sommes en direct avec jean-pierre
colombien ce porte parole de l'union des
policiers nationaux indépendants
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ces deux séquences sont
directement liés selon vous vous seriez
on vit on vit une période où tous les
prétextes seront seront bons pour
déclencher des guerres locales
il faut pas s'y tromper il faut pas se
tromper sur le contexte qui existe dans
ces secteurs
nous sommes face à de véritables
batailles rangées des des mini guerre
civile qui sont localisés à certains
quartiers au sein desquels il n'ya
strictement plus rien qui représente de
près ou de loin l'autorité d'état et
donc le moindre prétexte peut-être
l'opportunité donnée à des groupes de
délinquants à s'en donner à coeur joie
parce qu'il faut pas s'y tromper
faut pas tout mélanger faut pas faire
d'amalgamé
nous sommes face dans plupart du temps à
des groupes de délinquants qui profitent
de la dram en l'occurrence d'un garçon
présents qui n'ont comme à je crois
qu'on peut personne peut s'en réjouir
le par contre ce qui est lamentable
c'est de voir que ces événements assez
triste sont l'occasion le l'élément
déclenchant pour provoquer ce type
d'émeutes qui qui d'autre dans tout le
monde est victime faut pas imaginer que
les habitants de ces quartiers là sont
solidaires de ce qui s'y passe est
d'ailleurs j'aurai une petite
observation faire sur la façon dont ton
parfois certains médias couvrent des
événements de ce genre sur le jeu je
pense pas à vous notamment mais je pense
plutôt à un de vos confrères qui étaient
spécialisés en matière d'affaires
juridiques et qui dans le cadre du
procès de viry-châtillon noter que les
enquêtes de voisinage n'avait
strictement rien donné et que on pouvait
en conclure que les des habitants de ces
quartiers étaient d'une certaine manière
assez solidaire de ce qui s'y passait et
notamment de ses actes d'agression mais
c'est pas du tout ça c'est pas du tout
ça la vérité la vérité c'est que les
habitants de ces quartiers ont peur ils
sont simplement ils vivent simplement
sous la menace de groupes de familles
entières de délinquants qui n'hésiterait
pas dans le cas où il témoignait ou des
personnes témoigneront à
ainsi des mesures de représailles de
rétorsion contre ces personnes contre
ses résidents donc il ya un phénomène
qui sociale bien déterminée bien
identifiés qu'on connaît parfaitement
bien faut pas faire semblant comme le
font certains politiques ou certains
démagogues faire semblant de découvrir
ce qui se passe dans ces secteurs là il
faut simplement il faudrait simplement y
appliquer les mesures de rétorsion qui
soit durable et crédible ce qui n'est
pas le cas en ce moment s'il ne risque
pas d'être le cas en ce moment en tout
cas la police et est démuni face à à ces
séquences plusieurs témoins du quartier
de la duchère accuse notamment la police
d'avoir volontairement c'est tombé
l'adolescent qui ne portait pas de
casque
qu'est ce que vous leur répondre mais
c'est toujours toujours la même litanie
d'actes de violences volontaires contre
contre contre des jeunes que l'on
contrôle
non mais il faut arrêter ça c'est faux
il faut bloquer véritablement ce type de
dialogue qui ne mènent à rien il n'y a
pas de volonté de détruire un individu
ou un garçon à l'occasion d'un contrôle
c'est totalement faux c'est joli ccc de
nature ajustements alimenter des je
dirais des réflexes d'ultra violence et
qui sont l'occasion de burg brûlé la
voiture date elle de voler ou de piller
tel ou tel magasin alors ça ça n'a pas
de sens aller plus loin dans ce que vous
venez de dire il n'y a pas d'accusation
contre la police une abri ce qui ferait
mal son travail a surtout une absence de
police dans ces secteurs là on a enlevé
la police de proximité on a enlevé toute
présence de référence policière dans ces
sites dans ces secteurs et de fête
l'intervention des polices de quelques
police que ce soit est perçu comme une
agression extérieure et la régal à la
tap concert marié la pac le gouvernement
avait promis des renforts policiers dans
la commune parce que
la commune n'est pas la cible pour la
première fois des meutes on se souvient
de violence en octobre visiblement ces
renforts se font attendre mais non mais
il faut savoir de quoi on parle
parler de renforts ou d'interventions
ponctuelles loyer si c'est tout c'est de
la sémantique à là on est dans la
journée dans la parabole en aidant on
est dans la parole veines et vide de
sens quand on dit qu'on promet des
renforts souvent ça se ça se traduit par
des envois de crs ou de gardes mobiles
ou de compagnies d'intervention qui vont
rétablir un ordre il a une apparence
d'ordre républicain pendant un temps
donné
mais qui ne peuvent en aucun cas se
substituer à une police et une présence
policière durable et pérenne et
acceptées par tous et qu'ils soient là
pour établir un dialogue que ce soit un
dialogue sécuritaire ou un dialogue
citoyen on est loin de tout ça on n'est
que dans des queues dans des
déclarations je dirais de médiatique
destinée aux dires c'est avouer que
c'est destiné ce discours-là s'est passé
pas aux services de police ni aux élus
du terrain qu'ils connaissent
parfaitement la situation
c'est au niveau des eaux au niveau des
médias que ce que ce ce discours est
état dans ses missions de terrain les
policiers qui sont l'art du mois ce qui
reste de policiers savent très bien que
ce sont des paroles mais n'évitent de
sens des renforts il n'y en aura pas il
n'y en aura pas tout simplement parce
que les recrutements sont insuffisantes
parce que le déficit des des policiers
qui ont été retirés du terrain est telle
qu'il faudra des années pour ne pas dire
des dizaines d'années pour revenir à
niveau et ça monsieur darmana aussi bien
puisqu'il a été associé à monsieur
nicolas sarkozy pendant des années et
que pendant des années il a accompagné
la politique de déflation des effectifs
de police au niveau des secteurs
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne jean-pierre colombiès
elle porte parole de l'union des
policiers nationaux sur indépendant